the Trump administration is also
launching a major military operation to
quote harden the southern border and
block illegal immigration it includes
more than 5,000 active-duty troops to
help Customs and Border Patrol agents in
Texas Arizona and California the
president said last night he also plans
tent cities to hold migrants while they
apply for asylum in the US now the
operation targets a large caravan of
migrants from Central America that is
now moving through southern Mexico
luge's yang is at the White House where
the president has told would-be border
crossers our military is waiting for you
we show good morning good morning Nora
this plan is a promise kept by President
Trump who has recently ramped up the
threats of using military might to stop
that Caravan critics say it's just a
huge waste of taxpayer money and purely
political ahead of the midterm elections
the administration says it's just the
beginning I'm sending up the military
when you looked at that bridge loaded up
with people that's called an invasion of
our country in a late-night Fox News
interview President Trump touted the
military's deployments to the us-mexico
border when you look at that Caravan a
lot of bad people in there people that
are in gangs
we don't want them in this country as
part of Operation Faithful Patriot the
Pentagon is sending more than 5,200
troops to the southwest border in
addition to the more than 2,000 National
Guard already deployed there as well as
military helicopters and giant spools of
razor wire the first 800 troops are
focusing on southern Texas the closest
point of crossing for the caravan then
the military will head west to Arizona
and California regularly armed troops
will be allowed to carry their weapons
but military personnel don't have the
authority to apprehend illegal
immigrants instead they will install
barriers at ports of entry build houses
for Border Patrol agents and supply
equipment troops will also provide
flights to transport agents to areas
where they are needed the most
groups of migrants have already clashed
with police on the Mexico Guatemala
border reportedly leading to the death
of one migrant and injuries to several
officers in recent weeks the president
has put the caravan on center stage of
his campaign rallies and even though it
is about a thousand miles away he
insists the time to act is now we're not
letting them into this country the White
House is floating administrative options
to secure the border including shutting
it down altogether even to asylum
seekers meanwhile because that Caravan
is still so far away it's not expected
to reach the us-mexico border for
another month
at the earliest John we should thank you
you know elections are about what's the
turf you're fighting on sometimes
clearly the president wants this turf
for the last week to be about
immigration Democrats wanted to be about
health care and we saw Brad prep our
scale yes our scale yesterday the
president's campaign manager wants it to
be about the economy so what's it gonna
be well I think also when the president
says that he's going to do this there
are a few constitutional or immigration
experts who believe the president can do
such a move by executive order if he
tried to do it it would likely be
according to most experts quickly shot
down by by the courts well there's a
reason why it's been a constitutional
standard for 150 years so do you think
it's all about the timing
well he's happy to have that fight have
this debate because he keeps the topic
in the news and that's a topic that he
thinks works well for them the question
is whether his own folks believe that
and also whether voters believe it
nevermind are they're nowhere near the
US border yeah exactly a long way point